hey everyone this is lucy and today i'll
be talking about what a solutions
architect actually does at aws now this
is a highly requested video topic and
i've been getting this question ever
since i started my role as an associate
solutions architect at aws so i thought
i'd finally sit down and make a video to
address these three questions first of
all what does a solutions architect
actually do second of all what are some
of the roles and responsibilities of an
aws solutions architect and thirdly what
does my day look like as an associate
solutions architect at aws if you're
interested in learning more about the
role as a solutions architect the skills
required and how you can become a
solutions architect in 2022 make sure
you subscribe to the channel down below
and turn on notifications because i'll
be making videos about those topics very
very soon all right now let's head over
to the amazon jobs page
okay so according to the amazon's job
page the solutions architect team at aws
is responsible for helping customers
successfully implement cloud
technologies by partnering with internal
teams and leveraging a deep technical
knowledge of our tools and products
you'll craft highly scalable flexible
and resilient cloud architectures that
address our customers business problems
come join us in making the impossible
possible well that last sentence sounded
pretty cool and after working at aws for
around one and a half years now that
description actually makes a lot of
sense to me but i thought i add on to
this because after hearing about the
solutions architect role for the first
time it might be hard to figure out what
exactly we do and why aws actually needs
solutions architects in the first place
so without the help of a solutions
architect customers can still use the
products and services that aws offers
but with over 200 to choose from and
hundreds of pages of documentation about
how to use them it can be quite hard to
know what's the best solution for their
particular situation and this is where a
solutions architect comes in a solutions
architect is essentially a trusted
advisor for the customer as they go
through their journey with using the
cloud so aws solutions architects we
didn't actually go into the customer's
console and build everything out for
them we have other teams at aws to help
with that and we also collaborate with
other companies as well in order for
them to help the customer out with more
hands-on implementation but what we do
instead is we provide technical guidance
to help the customers make architectural
decisions that not only follow the best
practices but also making sure that the
solutions are secure performant cost
optimized and also fault tolerant now
when it comes to the roles and
responsibilities of a solutions
architect it does vary depending on the
team that you're in and the type of
solutions architect that you are so
there are many teams that we have at aws
there's the enterprise team there's a
smaller medium business team digital
native business team there are a few
different types of teams and these teams
are usually split up depending on the
different customers that we have at aws
but we also have other teams with
specialist essays that focus on a
specific knowledge domain for example
there's security specialist solutions
architects or solutions architects focus
more towards networking or databases but
generally speaking solutions architects
typically focus around half of their
time engaging with customers and helping
them out this could be through the form
of having a whiteboarding session where
you're showing them what an architecture
would look like if they were to move on
aws a solutions architect could also be
building out a proof of concept for a
customer and showcasing that through a
demo they could also be doing an
architectural review to help the
customers improve on their architecture
or they could be simply just helping the
customer out by answering some of their
questions either through email or
through a call so you might be wondering
well if half the time is spent with
customers what do essays do during the
other half of their time so the rest of
the time is typically split between
internal meetings speaking at events
writing blogs running technical
workshops sometimes mentoring other
solutions architects or even creating a
new program at aws that can provide some
sort of value at scale we also have
something we call sharpen the store time
where we cover up some time for learning
and this involves studying for adwords
certifications catch you up with new
product updates or diving deep into
learning more about a set of aws
services so the role of a solutions
architect really has many elements to it
part of it is talking to the customer
but as i mentioned there are also other
work that we do and so i wanted to share
what my day-to-day looks like as an
associate solutions architect a couple
of months ago i uploaded a video showing
you a day in my life as an associate
solutions architect in the admiss techie
program but since then i've officially
graduated from that techie program and
joined my current team where i'm working
with customers and helping them
accelerate their cloud journey so as you
probably hear just like any other role
in the tech industry no two days are the
same the main distinction between an
associate solutions architect versus a
solutions architect is that we have a
lot more guidance and support when it
comes to learning so what i do is i can
spend a lot of my time doing shadowing
and reverse shadowing different
customers so if i ever want to receive
feedback on how i'm talking in front of
a customer and how i'm engaging with the
customer i can ask a more senior essay
to reverse shadow me and that way i can
get some feedback that's what i spend a
lot of my time doing these days still
doing a lot of learning doing aws
certifications my next goal is to
complete the advs security specialty
certification and there's also a lot of
meetings as well throughout the day in
the form of internal meetings team
stand-ups we also have a bunch of
customer meetings something else i'm
doing in aws is helping students and
people earning their career learn more
about cloud and also develop career
ready skills alright so this brings us
to the very end of this video thank you
so much for watching and if you have any
questions please leave it down below and
give this video a like if you learned
something new about the sa roll bye for
now